good morning everyone on the 15th of
august we commemorate the 75th
anniversary
of bj day four months after ve day
and which marked the final end of the
second world war
a war which involved at least 25
countries
and resulted in between 55 and 59
million deaths
for the first time in a war military
casualties were outnumbered by civilian
casualties
being approximately two-thirds of the
total
in the pacific campaign the number of
civilian deaths
was in need in a higher proportion
although to many in great britain
it was far away and sometimes apparently
forgotten
the pacific campaign covers a large
proportion of
pacific motion south and southeast asia
from as far south as northern australia
to the aleutian islands in the north
the war ended following the decision by
the allies to use for the first time
atomic weapons at a dreadful human cost
and ushered the world into a terrifying
new age
nevertheless the use of those two atomic
bombs
ended the deadliest of all wars swiftly
with given the casualties already
incurred
in the pacific theater far fewer deaths
than any alternative so on the 15th we
commemorate
without as a result pandemic
any fanfare the end of a truly dreadful
conflict
and whilst the numbers of those who
remember the conflict are few
the sacrifice of those involved whether
military or civilian
in europe or asia must never be
forgotten
and must be an everlasting lesson of the
importance of dialogue and peace
rather than the alternative on behalf of
my fellow members and the staff of
stratfor district council
and the residents of this district let
us thank
all those from this area for their
sacrifices on this veggie day
and pray for peace christopher kettle
chairman of stratfor district council
thank you for listening
goodbye